إنه عداءي الثاني ولا
أطيق الانتظار
واستمتع بالموسيقى ،
أنت تعرف ما يقوله بعض الناس ، لا
تحتاج إلى
القيام بذلك ، لا أعلم أن كل هذا خطأ ، نعم ،
دعني وشأني تريد أن تفعل ذلك ، هل أنت
نعم أنت  87 عامًا ، نعم وما
زلت تريد الصيام بالطبع أفعل
ذلك ، نعم ، إنها حياتي ، نعم
المسلمون هم حياتي
وستظل دائمًا حتى أذهب إلى
الجنة
[موسيقى
] تبدو مارشا جميلة ، أليس كذلك ،
أنا أحبها نعم
[موسيقى]
شالوم
هو آخر 10 أيام من شهر
رمضان
الآن ونحصل على الكثير من
البركات وأود أن أعطي المال
لجلب الأطفال الأيتام وأمهاتهم
لمساعدة الأطفال
في طعامهم وملابسهم
ومساعدتهم في أمور أخرى  طرقًا أيضًا في
التعليم
[الموسيقى]
ثم فجأة
صدمني شيء ما في رأسي كنت
بمفردي وفي قلبي
أخبرني أحدهم أن
ماريا تمضي قدمًا
كمسلم ،
لقد كانت قوية جدًا من العدم
[موسيقى]
الله
هناك تذهب مبروك